David Newton covers the Panthers for
espn.com kind enough to join us David
good morning thanks for joining us what
do you make after this confrontation
well Dana I've seen a lot of weird
things happen in Cam Newton's career
this is one of the more weirder is crazy
the fact that Kelvin Benjamin called it
out in the first place because Kelvin
Benjamin has never gotten more attention
than when he played with Cam Newton but
what happened on the field to me was
really strange I mean Kelvin said all
these things but he hasn't stand behind
what he said I mean you could question
whether Cam should have going over there
and and you know it stood up before him
before the game but cancer God wants to
know what's going on there they were
good buddies he called him Benji he I
mean Kelvin Benjamin dressed up as an
elf or Cam to deliver Christmas gifts
the first few years they were in the
league so what exactly happened now
heard rumors that maybe there was a
little disagreement between the two at
some point in the last year but again
kin has stood up for Kelvin Benjamin
throughout his career when he was hurt
during his rookie season when he made
mistakes made he to go after
or work hard to go after a guy after
those intercession he stood up for him
and the fact that Kelvin caught him out
was just crazy but I guess a system
continued to go on after what happened
last night because Kelvin even though he
said he was moving on did nothing to do
what he said yeah I was surprised with
the comments but I don't know the
backstory if there is a backstory I
thought that they got along and
everything I read about them is that
they got along but you're not sure if
there was did Cam care of Kelvin been
caroling I kept Kelvin Benjamin yeah I
mean he was really you could tell the
day after this happened to the trade
last year that cam was a little bit
upset about it I mean he really was
close to Kelvin he liked him as a target
as a player they had a really good
rookie year for kelvins rookie year
together because Kelvin again had it
what a thousand yards even and led the
team in receptions I mean he was had a
really good season there and to put it
all the blame on Cam Newton I thought
was a little strange so yeah again it's
a puzzle to me and maybe we'll never
notice Kim Kim won't speak about it he's
trying to take the high road at all this
and he's the only commented on a social
maybe has not talked to us the camp's
I'll be curious until address at this
coming week which I doubt he will he has
some odd body language and you're around
him a lot and I and I mentioned this
that you know he's grinning as he's
saying something to Kelvin Benjamin his
hands are behind his back and it's weird
body language there I don't think you're
a body language expert but I'm gonna ask
you to read into it what it what is like
ham it looks passive-aggressive like hey
what's up man and my hands are behind my
back so I'm sort of coming in he tried
to shake his hand but to me it feels
like I still want to talk to you I got a
problem here and I want to talk to you I
was surprised that they did it on the
football field in front of everybody
including cam spotting a camera over
Thomas Davis's shoulder yeah that was
the biggest thing I mean they could have
settled this off the field when you know
the teams arrived but they didn't Kant
chose to wait there I say the fact that
time of Stavis was already confronting
Kelvin about this kind of camp probably
felt maybe it's okay if I go over there
and and kind of see what's going on
because Thomas is the senior leader on
the team and Thomas seemed to be smiling
a little bit the cams expression after
Kelvin didn't take his hand for the
handshake really turned to more of a
puzzlement there and just I think the
fact he kept his hands behind his back
was just saying hey I'm not gonna make
this a confrontation but he started it
by going over there and talking to him
so it was kind of a confrontation I
think cam just wants to know what's up
and I don't know if he questions as much
about what Kelvin said about his
accuracy because that's pretty little
document and I think the football
knowledge probably got to him more than
that and I think he just want to know
why Kelvin said these things and I guess
he felt betrayed and all this that's the
biggest thing I got from it and you know
what I gave I took away the part you
just singled out where he's really
testing he see he's questioning his
football IQ and as a black quarterback
and as we know what has happened you
know in the history of the NFL like I
don't need Kelvin Benjamin to be
questioning my football IQ all these
people questioned my football IQ leading
up to the draft now I got a former
teammate who's saying this you might say
I wasn't accurate
but that one I think is the one that
stung pretty deep went pretty deep on
cam no I totally agree I didn't you go
back and look at the other quarterbacks
that Kelvin mentioned there one of them
was Eli Manning if you go back and look
at Eli Manning's career completion
percentage the first ten years of his
career it was worse than Cam Newton so
that really didn't have any validity to
it so and Kelvin you know he's a guy
that when he was at Carolina he seemed
to make excuses at times I don't even
get the fact that he brought up the
whole death of his mom and the fact he
didn't get the morning bat and he felt
like that was on the Panthers - I
thought they did give him a chance to
mourn he did come to camp and try to
prepare right away but he's put on
social media right after that happened
how being around his teammates and the
coaches was helping him with the healing
process and where all this came from I
mean I know he said he was angry when he
did the interview but he hasn't said
what he was angry about so again if
somebody comes out here and explains it
in more detail I'm just kind of a loss
of words with it Carolina more likely to
go ten and six or six and ten I think 10
is six I think the weapons they put
around cam dude I think they're the best
weapons he's ever had I know there's a
lot of young guys they've gotta depend
on but I really like DJ more you saw
some what he could do last night I like
what they've gotten Curtis Samuel who is
their second-round pick last year
Christian McCaffrey is they get to 25
the 30 touches a game that Ron Rivera
and the alternates say that they want to
get out of him I think he's going to
have a really big year I mean you saw
what he could do with a couple of cases
last night what 29 yards from those he
showed you can run between two tackles
with the touchdown run so I think you're
gonna see more the Christian McCaffrey
saw who the star player at Stanford than
you saw last year where it was kind of
the change of pace back for Jonathan
Stewart instead they're gonna have a
change of pace back for Christian
McCaffrey David thank you for joining us
have a great weekend we appreciate your
time thank them that's David Newton he
covers the Panthers for espn.com for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]